Let's consider a
ball that is dropped
from a certain height, h i,
above the ground and this ball
is falling.
It hits the ground
and it bounces up
until it reaches some
final height, h final.
Now when the ball is
colliding with the ground,
there are collision forces.
And in this problem
what we like to do
is figure out what the
average force of the ground
is on the ball.
And that will be
the normal force,
the average normal force, on
the ball during the collision.
Now if we look at
this ball dropping,
it's going to lose a
little bit of energy,
because it's getting
compressed at the collision.
Let's look at an example of
the actual ball dropping.
As you can see in
this high speed video,
as the ball falls down, it
collides with the ground.
When it collides with the
ground, it's compressed.
And then as it rebounds
upwards, the ball
expands back to
its original shape,
but it doesn't quite get
to the same height-- that's
because when the
ball is compressed,
there's some deformation in the
rubber structure of the ball,
and it's not a completely
elastic deformation.
And so some of the energy
is transformed into, first,
molecular motions, which turn
into thermal energy that's
radiative into the environment.
Let's look in particular at
the details of the collision.
If we look at it in slow
motion what we have here--
and I'll draw a picture--
as the ball is colliding
with the ground,
ball compresses,
expands as it goes upwards.
And so we can draw a free
body diagram of the ball
with a normal force and
a gravitational force.
Now let's choose our
positive direction up.
So now what we'd like to do is
apply the momentum principle
to analyze the
average normal force.
And our momentum principle,
remember is impulse.
The force integrated over
some time during the collision
is equal to the
change in momentum.
So what we'd like
to do is identify
the states that are relevant.
So it will have a state
before, so what we'll do
is we'll call this
the before state,
and that's right before the
ball is hitting the ground.
And we have an after state,
and in the after state,
the ball has now finished
colliding with the ground,
and it's now moving
up with speed up.
Now again, we're going
to choose a positive up.
Here on representing
things as it speeds.
One of the things, we
need some times here,
so let's say that t initial is
zero, this is our final time.
We'll call this time
the before time,
we'll just call this t
before, and this is t after.
And then our integral
is going from before to
after the momentum.
And we can now apply
the momentum principle.
Well, this is a vector equation
and we've chosen unit vectors
up, so what we have
here is the integral
of from t before to t after of
N minus mg, integrated over dt,
and that's equal to
the momentum at the y
component of the
momentum at t after,
minus the y component
of the momentum.
We don't have a
vector here anymore.
The y component of
the vector, t before.
And so this is our expression
of the momentum principle.
Impulse causes
momentum to change.
Now we're assuming that the
normal force just averaging it
and so this intregral simply
becomes N average minus
ng, times the time of collision,
is equal to-- now in here
we can put the mass of the
ball, we have the velocity.
Now here's where we
have to be a little bit
careful, because we're
looking at the y component.
We chose speed downwards, that's
in the negative y direction,
so we have minus-- sorry,
we're looking at after.
We have plus V after, because
this is going in the positive j
direction.
And over here we
have a negative mass,
but it's going in
the minus direction,
so we have a minus
mV before, and so we
get mass times V
after plus V before.
So our first result is that
the normal force average.
Let's bring the divide
through by delta t,
and bring the Ng term over,
so we have m Va plus Vb,
divided by delta t, plus mg.
So we see that if the
collision time is very short,
then this average force
is a little bit bigger.
A long collision time,
the average force
a little bit smaller.
Now from kinematics, we already
have worked out the problem
that the speed
for an object that
rises to a height, h final,
this is the velocity afterwards,
is just square
root of 2g h final.
And in a similar way, if an
object is falling height h i,
the speed when it gets
to the bottom is 2ghi.
And so now we can conclude
with these substitutions
that the average force equals
m times square root of 2g h
final, plus the square
root of 2g h initial,
over the collision
time, plus and mg.
And of course the
collision time,
we're saying is t
after minus t before.
And so that's how we can
use the momentum principle
to get an average expression
for the normal force.